oh yes you're the gold state killer yeah
all these years yeah you're the golden
shower killer oh wait a minute hey if
they got DNA in 30 years what are they
gonna have besides DNA are they gonna be
able to tap into your brain and get a
map of your brain dude you know what
they're gonna have which is horrifying
as your old headshots Nick it's not that
bird it's not that what bird mm it's not
it's not that much of a burn stop
covering them oh my god it's not that
big of a bird it's not that bad oh
that's so obnoxious oh all right oh all
right
got me a little bit you didn't get me a
lot ah you are gonna have you're gonna
have to go out of your [ __ ] stone no
why'd you drink you out of your seat dog
but crazy that's from the 40s Nick oh my
gosh gee whiz if he sees that shot
gee whiz you out of your stone why is he
here like why'd you do it
none of your beeswax it would be cool of
angels I don't swim look at Charlie
Chaplin I know we saw Brian live that's
so easy yawning is that what he's doing
there so not cool to say that about me
no you heard those are great jeans I
don't know Levi has made spray they're
not there Levi's make spray paint the
famous oh my god so much fun we should
get a timeshare together three of us
yeah three I like that like will cook
dog oh yeah I just made up for your
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh yeah great that's the
name of your special [ __ ] [ __ ] look
at that that's your special that's your
album that's your [ __ ] stamp I'm
getting that's your grill oh yeah
sigh no I'm not doing that make you a
grill right now oh yeah yeah smile
he needs my skin is so good though I
have good skin oh yeah thank you
hey Nick I look 51 okay no you know you
do have good skin yeah yeah housewives
is a bummer
how old are you Nick 41 goddamn dude
I've really known you since you were 19
yeah literally a weird
crazy that is [ __ ] weird men you do
have good skin though yeah who's your
dermatologist or bill or that's not I
don't even think it's funny dude so why
are you lying a joke you're laughing at
your own joke no I wasn't yeah you were
you know I got a lot your beard Chuck so
I mean it's not you're serious it's not
great watch all the sports
yeah Brian we can't just all sit around
and watch figure skating like you do you
know what I mean
people like want to watch sports some
type sports yeah and I know yeah drama
yeah we can't just sit there in your
living room usually for most our cows me
ask you this huh finally what you won't
know these names but would you rather be
Tom Brady and Derek Jeter or LeBron
James yeah did miss rice like what who
are those people it's not a good
impression of oh my god Kevin that's a
[ __ ] I've never done that that's what
you do lot Maya's earth friends separate
flattering
my friends sister it's muted [ __ ]
lizard makes me think of Brian skin when
I hear that so it's like a lot less feel
like you could you just said I
definitely get a dick thing to say
although I had psoriasis so just don't
be weird your socks go bro up sub bad
dude I know while talking to you why
wouldn't I give that to you as it's a
gift it's a gift it's a gift